you're at the point in life where you
know your career is in Show Business it
wasn't always like that when you were a
young man there was no indication that
you would be in Show Business I think
until until about five or six years into
the Late Night show I don't think there
was any you never had a career plan no I
know that's what I like about you did
you quit school at 16 I did you did did
your parents flip out they they were a
little upset about it yeah because you
know from where I come from the only
real way out of of kind of difficult
circumstances is to get because Scotland
is good about giving away free education
I mean they they do give it away if you
have the application to get it but at 16
you're allowed to leave school yeah you
are and I did you get out of school you
figure hey maybe I'll be an electrician
you try that and then the punk scene
happens punk rock that was liberating
and and you were like well I can
do this yeah all of a sudden you never
took music lessons right you were not a
musician no and you decide well I'll
play drums in a punk band yeah now now
can it really be that simple my older
brother had had a drum kit that he
didn't use it was it was lying around
you know in this kind of garage thing
that was next to the house so I'd go in
and play it and because I had a drum kit
that was enough like when punk started
people forget this now but everybody was
in a band right everybody was in a band
did you have the whole look oh yeah yeah
what I used to do was like I had to wear
my school uniform to go to school or so
I'd take that and then I'd go out at
night and then there was a bridge near
my house and I would dress you know put
on a trash bag and safy pins and hide my
clothes under the bridge so you do this
punk band thing for a while and then you
and a buddy decide I guess in the punk
band if I got this right you guys you
know you decide to try some stand-up
comedy you would started to learn about
American comedians well that was Peter
Capaldi who is the actor at plays the
doctor and Doctor Who and that we were
in a band together and and Peter was
he's like a very Arty guy he's very like
he's my he was a very good friend and he
was a singer and a band I was in and we
were really good buddies and he he went
to art school and he was from a like a
he was a clever guy and I'd never really
met anyone like him before and he loved
American stand-up comedians he had
Richard Pryor albums and Steve Martin
albums and you didn't know anything
about that no no it was not a world I
understood I knew about Billy connley
and I love Billy like Billy was like
Jackie Robinson yeah he's in England and
Scotland he's in Scotland and he sounds
like me and he's kind of from my
background and he's 20 years older than
me so he's just in that sweet spot like
he's in his 30s and becoming F again you
didn't you didn't sit there and
fantasize about being a funny guy on
stage no no but but he he had kind of
presented the the fact that it it was
somehow on in the Horizon that it just
never existed before and you started
writing sitcoms and stuff and then you
got the gig on Drew carry do I have this
right yeah yeah you do and then you're
the you're his boss for eight years and
you probably like I'm really in
Show Business I'm the boss on Drew Cary
and Drew Cary yeah I was like the
English guy like car you're fire and
they were all nice to me and it was a
decent gig and that was eight seasons
you got out of debt I mean you're in
show business but nobody thought of you
like oh oh this is the next big late guy
or anything but I think what happened is
I I got when Craig kilborne left right
and they did a bunch of try out shows
yeah and I I did them because they asked
me to do it I had been a guest on
actually Conan show Peter Lali had seen
me being on Conan they liked you as a
guest they liked me as a guest and so
they asked me to come and do a guest
host and then Peter Lali believed in me
and that was really it cuz Peter was so
powerful and so influential and so
clever about that thing and Peter Lali
who was originally Johnny Carson's guy
and then went went with Letterman and
Letterman's production company owned the
time slot that's the thing they were
able to hire you they created an
environment which I don't think will
ever exist in television again it was
this weird Confluence of events because
CBS had so wanted Letterman to go there
in the early 90s that they had given
them and it was a really smart idea cuz
they wouldn't have gotten them otherwise
they gave him two hours of real estate
right gave him 11:30 to 1:30 in the
morning so Dave only cared really about
his show you know Dave like anything
outside his building is he's not even
seen it but Johnny Carson had that same
deal with the network at NBC he had
certain deals so Dave always tried to
get the same deal Johnny Carson had
because Dave Dave was like you obsessed
with Johnny he was like a fan of Johnny
and I I didn't really know about this
world at all no you were not like a late
night talk show Enthusiast right no no
but but Peter schooled me in it because
he was like he was like Yoda you know he
knew everything about and he would teach
me how to like you know wear your tie
like this don't do your cre apparently
had a creepy laugh when I started so he
like don't do your creepy laugh you're
creeping people out and he's just like
he's such a gentleman and he's so kind
of classy and he was like Yoda to you
yeah and it was yeah when you say it was
a perfect storm you got hired because
Letterman on the time slot Peter Lali
was his guy L's your fan those guys go
to bad for you they don't have to go to
the network really they own the own it
yeah and you get to be the host yeah
when you they first gave you a talk show
and since you had never done one and and
weren't really into that whole system
right you kind of approach it like an
actor you watched reges you watched
Letterman and and me and you say okay if
I had to act like these guys what would
I do so when you first get on you're
sort of acting your way through it right
you're faking it and then you got to
find your way so I mean that's a hell of
a way to enter a job you know where you
haven't even just had a chance to sort
of formul and and I would it never have
worked if the situation had not existed
where I was protected by Dave's
deal